asumió formalmente como Primer Ministro
de Reino Unido luego de jurar ante el
Rey Carlos III en el Palacio de
buckingham
[Música]
uniré a nuestro país no con palabras
sino con acciones
trabajaré día a día para cumplirles
este gobierno tendrá integridad
profesionalismo y responsabilidad en
todos los niveles
la confianza se gana y yo me ganaré la
de ustedes
el premiere más joven que ha tenido
Reino Unido en 200 años también dio a
conocer a su equipo de gobierno entre
aliados y amigos cercanos el nuevo
gabinete británico tiene muchas caras
conocidas el ministro de finanzas que
llegó a desmantelar el polémico plan
fiscal de la ex Premier
continuará al mando de la economía los
ministros de defensa de relaciones
exteriores y de interior también
tuvieron continuidad en sus cargos el
ministro de justicia y la encargada de
la cartera de Educación estuvieron
también en el gabinete de Boris Johnson
Grand Shops será el secretario comercial
y mells el jefe del departamento de
trabajo y pensiones mientras Penny
Morgan quien inicialmente competía por
el 10 de Down en Street con Richi sunat
seguirá como líder del partido en la
cámara de los comunes los secretarios de
medio ambiente salud y Transporte
también fueron conocidos